Okay.
Let's start by looking at what
each of these platforms offer.
Google Cast provides a simple
sender receiver typology
which allows developers to
create multi device experiences
integrated with their existing
apps on Android, iOS, and the web.
Android TV simply takes Android and
brings it into the living room.
This makes it a deal for
extending your existing Android app
to work in the living room whether or
not the user has their phone on them.
You can integrate your service or
app with Google Cast, Android TV, or
even better both.
Where to start and how to go further
depends on the type of service and
what platforms are already integrated.
In many case you can then extend
to cover multiple platforms for
the greatest impact and
best user experience regardless of
what the user has driving their TV.
The most common use case I hear
talked about is streaming media.
Whether your app is on Android, iOS or
web your first step in building for
the living room is adding in
Google Cast functionality.
Now this will ensure your users will
be able to stream on all Google Cast
ready devices including chrome cast and
Android TV.
Once you've finished adding Google Cast
support you can then extend your Android
app using your lean back library.
Allowing your users to launch and
control the app from their Android TV.
Beyond this common use case,
it really depends what platform you're
already working on and therefore the
platform from which you're extending.
If you've already got an Android app,
it can most easily be extended with a
lean back library to work on Android TV.
In fact, many Android apps for
the phone, tablet, and
TV will all be bundled
in the same app package,
which simplifies the Google Play
experience for users.
In essence, the TV is just
another form factor for your app.
If you've got a web app, it can most
easily be extended to the living room by
using the Google Cast platform.
The Chrome API takes care
of rendering the app and
then streaming that content
to the Cast device.
If you've already got an iOS app, it can
also easily be extended to the living
room by using the Google Cast SDK for
iOS.